It's a big day we're gonna get god come
again christian god is real he's been
asleep for thousands of years we're gonna
sneak up there and get him mob style zwack
is asking can i kill god off summer i'm the
next rick and morty me hunt me somebody hug me
don't hurt the completion everyone start packing
and no no time to explain rick dad what's wrong
a lot of people out there want a piece of
this sweetie i'm cool and it makes them
feel bad so you know after that trouble
with space beth i made passable copies
of the family and place them around the
country as a buffer zone to protect why
does he always want to be hunted jerry's
not important right now dad something's off
there is only one name that rick
fears what and that name is nimbus
who is that i am mr nimbus he's gonna say that a
lot mr nimbus has been talked about here and there
for a while nimbus who is that he was in another
episode that died mr nimbus but we all loved
nimbus so much we were just waiting for a chance
to use him he's king of the ocean and he's a
piece of nimbus kind of is the antithesis
of rick maybe he's the purest form of rick
i used to fear you respect you now all that's
left is pity nimbus actually is happy with himself
because he knows he's the king of the ocean and he
controls the police he's an ice-cold dick killer
how many enemies do you have to have why
is everything a fight with you you're not
gonna learn this early morty life is a fight
you know morty can be on the higher ground a
lot cause he's this young innocent kid and
rick is like you watch you'll make enemies
in your life no matter how well intentioned
you are looks like you can use a hand oh hey
rick has a mini portal to a pocket dimension
where there's a time dilation each generation
of the hoovey world needed to be updated in their
costumes also keeping alive in their iconography
the banners on their castles the holograms
in the future world all have demonic images
of morty on them their entire culture is based
around this folk demon of the boy in the portal
such a waste i just love giant time birds at
the end of existence there's no reason for
there to be a giant time bird it doesn't really
make sense but i uh i did insist on it catch a
new episode next sunday at 11 p.m something's
off on adult swim
Welcome back everyone, this
is going to be my new rick and morty season
5 episode 2 trailer video and the cold open
the opening scene from the episode if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the episodes i'm doing videos for all the rick and
morty episodes for season five just like i've done
in previous seasons we're doing a giveaway for
rick and morty merch 2. all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your favorite
easter egg from the series so far on the video
careful for spoilers if you did not see episode 1
yet just because we'll be covering everything from
the series so far but episode 2 is titled morty
plicity and it's a reference to the michael keaton
movie multiplicity from the 90s michael keaton is
having a bit of a major comeback in hollywood the
last 10 years or so like they're actually filming
the flash movie with his version of batman from
the tim burton movies that's right they're using
the multiverse as a trope in the dc movies now
so the bringing him back is sort of like the
60-something batman beyond version of batman
but the movie multiplicity bears some similarity
to the plot of this episode as you see in the cold
open in the trailer sometimes the titles of the
episodes don't have a whole lot to do with the
actual plot but in that movie michael keaton
finds a way to clone himself and tries to use
the clones to slack off and just do all of his
work for him until the clones start to assert
themselves they have this big rebellion and he has
to sort everything out by the end of the film but
the happy ending is the clones do wind up moving
far away and opening a pizza business together
pretending to be triplets under a different name
so that movie did have a happy ending rick and
morty episodes don't always have a happy ending
like they don't always completely reset everything
like a traditional animated sitcom but in the
opening scene we're watching one of rick's clone
families get attacked by some aliens for unknown
reasons because as rick has said in the past
there's always something that was his big speech
to morty in episode one when morty was trying to
justify going off the rails starting this holy
war with an alternate dimension because he just
wanted to get some wine for jessica so that he
could get with her morty's like there was a guy
in the thing and rick tries to tell him there's
always going to be a guy in the thing trying to
mess with your plans so just get used to it then
rick specifically calls out the events of the
season 4 finale season 4 episode 10 was space beth
and how the galactic federation invaded the planet
because of what she had been doing on her space
adventures and because she was a version of beth
the federation was able to track her to her home
on earth or what they thought was her home even
though the episode tried to be ambiguous about
which beth was the clone and which beth was the
original they turned that into a whole big thing
i know you're all still wondering about who's the
real beth who's the clone beth you could argue
it either way but if you actually listen to dan
harmon's commentary that he did separate from the
episode about the way that they wrote the episode
in particular they actually did know who the real
beth was they did make a decision about that when
they were first breaking the episode he made it
sound like when they were writing the early drafts
space beth really was supposed to be the real
beth meaning that after season three after that
episode where he gives her the idea she would have
accepted his offer to clone her allowing her to go
off and have adventures around the multiverse
and then come back whenever she wanted and
theoretically they just get rid of the clone when
she did that she just stepped back into her life
like nothing had changed but then they said they
thought the episode would be better if they made
the clones identity more ambiguous which is where
the whole subplot about rick not wanting to know
came from now wanting to know which daughter was
the clone reinforcing the idea that he's supposed
to be a terrible dad who doesn't want to take
responsibility for anything speaking of which also
from that episode the season 4 finale he still has
phoenix person chilling out in the wall in pieces
until you see him bring him back you just have
to assume he's still chilling out in that wall
they did say they would be bringing space beth
back sometime during season five but they didn't
say which episode so it could be episode two more
duplicity because rick is name-dropping her in the
episode here but that could just be a verbal
reference and she doesn't show up till later
in the season like this is just foreshadowing like
oh we're gonna name drop her because she's coming
back sometime later it would be kind of weird
if they brought her back so soon even when they
bring back mr poopy butthole every single season
they tend to space out his episodes a bit more
but rick explains that because space beth can
be traced back to them again alien races wanting
revenge looking for her home he created all these
clone duplicate families around the world as a
buffer zone and during the cold open here one
of them has just been terminated the funny thing
here too is if you remember some of the other
trailer footage from the earlier season 5 trailers
you see that right after this scene another one
of those alien ships the aquatic looking aliens
come and vaporize the family's car so it sounds
like they're going to be a couple knee-jerk left
turns during the opening parts of the episode
where you have rick saying oh we have to bail
everyone one of the clone families just got killed
they jump in the car to escape but then they get
killed and it's revealed that they're another one
of the clone families like we don't catch up with
c-137 rick till a little bit later in the episode
the whole bit with this doll that they're chasing
around too i'm mister always wants to be hunted
seems like some sort of creepy mr booby butthole
looking version of a teddy ruxpin or a care bear
or some animatronic bear from the 80s or 90s
it feels like it's supposed to be some parody of
some 80s collectible toy that people get tired
of really fast like how long do you think this
would last you being interesting so post all
your theories about which toy this is supposed
to be a parody of it also feels kind of like a
metaphor for the episode for rick and i guess you
could say for space beth too because of the whole
twist of this episode and that rick does really
kind of want to be left alone but he also kind of
gets off on the whole adventure of it all fighting
alien races proving himself superior to everyone
including people that want to kill him space beth
is also just a much more rick-like version of beth
so she's a lot like that too so yes he hates
having to go through the trouble of creating
all these duplicate families all these contingency
plans but he also kind of likes being hunted too
he kind of gets off on it because unless you're
talking about the mr nimbus jokes from episode 1
like jeff loveness the writer made that joke he's
the only person that rick is afraid of rick isn't
really afraid of any alien races there's also a
bunch of other trailer footage from the earlier
trailers where you see a bunch of aquatic looking
ships flying around towards this hologram here you
also see a bunch of versions of rickship disguised
as alien ships amongst these two so this feels a
little bit like that multiplicity twist where
you have a bunch of versions of rick's families
all kind of warring with each other because
they're all finding out that they're duplicates
fighting for supremacy who's the real version of
the family who's the fake version if you didn't
see the invincible animated series that amazon
did it's based on robert kirkman's comic book they
actually had a twist like that during the series
where you have an alien that clones himself that's
one of his big things and they're always fighting
over who's the real one and who's the clone
they also kind of did that during season three's
rest in rick's laxation where you have toxic rick
thinking himself the supreme version of rick
like no i'm going to be the one that's going
to live out here in the real world you're going
to be the one that's going to go down and live in
this toxic environment so rick fighting versions
of himself isn't a brand new thing that even goes
back to season one with the whole idea of the
evil rick and evil morty that was behind him
i don't know if all these aliens are connected to
the voltron kaiju footage too because the designs
of the kaiju aliens seem similar to the designs
of some of these alien warriors in the suits
i also love the way they open that with them
talking about going to kill god so nonchalantly
like oh yeah he's real we're going to get him
right now but the way they pull back on that is
by saying that this family was fake they're not
actually doing that during the episode that's
the way a lot of animated series like this can
get away with edgier jokes by pulling it back
like say no see it was just a bit we were doing
within the episode it's not actually happening
in the episode the whole thing with season five
sort of returning to form is that they're airing
all ten episodes for season five without any
huge breaks between the episodes which is great
but that also means that they're still finishing
work on the last couple of episodes right up until
the last minute just because animation on rick
and morty takes way longer to complete than other
more simple animation series like south park which
is very purposefully made to look very crappy even
though they do it all in computer animation so for
example they'll be finishing rick and morty season
5 episode 10 that finale right up until the last
minute right before they're forced to deliver it
to adult swim so they can air it on television
so the other good news too for future seasons
is that the wait between seasons wouldn't be quite
as long anymore there wouldn't be any huge breaks
so rick and morty season six will premiere
around this time next year and the schedule will
mostly be the same like right now they're actually
starting work or they're in the middle of working
on rick and morty season seven but that's really
just writing the episodes but if you spotted any
more easter eggs in this trailer footage that
i didn't talk about in the video let me know
in the comments below in my full rick and morty
season 5 episode 2 video we'll post monday just
like normal in my full loki episode 4 video
we'll post wednesday there's a couple other
bonus videos that i'm working on that'll post
before then if you have any big questions or
rick and morty bonus videos that you want me
to make just let me know in the comments below
congratulations prince zodiac you're the giveaway
winner from my last big rick and morty video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact details
everyone click here for my full rick
and morty season 5 episode 1 video
and click here for my brand new Shang Chi
trailer video with the abomination versus wong
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!